NARRATOR: Sirpur, India.
The Surang Tila temple.
This structure, which dates
back to the seventh century AD,
was recently
unearthed after being
buried by a powerful
earthquake that
occurred in the 11th century.
Although the rest of the
area was completely leveled,
the structure itself
remained largely intact.
Archaeologists
suggest that this is
due to the advanced
construction techniques,
known as Ayurvedic or
Vedic architecture,
utilized by its builders.
The principles they
used are derived
from the ancient science of
design that can be traced back
to the ancient Indian texts.
In March 2017, researcher and
ancient astronaut theorist,
Giorgio Tsoukalos,
traveled to India
to meet with
archaeologist, Dr. Arun
Sharma, who headed the dig.
This is beautiful.
Really?
Now is this considered Ayurvedic
architecture right here?
That's amazing.
Huh.
OK.
NARRATOR: Although
much of the site
has been renovated
using modern concrete,
blocks held together
by the Ayurvedic paste
can still be found.
It seems to be almost
like some type of glue.
NARRATOR: The
glue-like substance
is said to form a bond
that is at least 20
times stronger than concrete.
But modern builders have
been unwilling to entertain
the notion that such
an ancient concoction
could be superior to
today's building materials.
Wow, look at this.
Beautiful.
NARRATOR: The
detailed instructions
for making this paste can be
found in an ancient Indian text
known as the "Mayamatam,"
a manuscript dedicated
to construction techniques.
The information contained
within the document
is understood to have
been passed down to humans
from Mayasura, the ancient king
of the demi-gods, who was said
to oversee various
construction projects on Earth,
including cities in the sky.
Curiously, there is a more
astounding earthquake-proof
feature at the site,
which indicates
that advanced knowledge was
used in its construction.
Located at key points within
the Surang Tila temple
are several 80-foot
long shafts, designed
to form air pockets
that can dissipate
the impact of seismic events.
Yes please.
GIORGIO TSOUKALOS: All right.
GIORGIO TSOUKALOS: Wow.
Oh wow, this is big.
It's a huge book.
And this text has been
around for 4,500 years.
In your opinion, where did
this knowledge come from?
And you think
that this knowledge
originated from the stars?
It's amazing.
NARRATOR: According
to the Hindu faithful,
the construction techniques
used at the Surang Tila temple
are just one example of
advanced technology detailed
in the ancient Sanskrit texts.
Other works are said
to contain information
far beyond the scope
of early man, perhaps
even providing concrete proof
of extraterrestrial activity
on earth.